歡迎收看
台大林秀的歌有仇必報
這個歌有仇必報的第二季
真的是千呼萬喚才把小哥請回來
所以小哥也決定呢
把很多過去也許教過大家的課程
再深入的探討一次
因為為什麼呢
我們根據一年四季
每一季籌碼會有不同的變化喔
像最近的籌碼在做什麼呢
最近的籌碼因為
最近的筹码
因为即将在五六月
有除全席
有股东会
最近的筹码面临
强制回补潮
也就是可能很多人去放空
对不对
这个空单要强制回补了
做空我们之前教过
但是如果空单被强制回补的时候
反而会酝酿所谓的什么
嘎空行情
每次说做空
就很多的观众朋友会来骂我们
觉得做空好像是在欺负韭菜
没关系
今天教你欺负空单
好不好
欺负空单
对不对
这个市场很奇妙
其实做空不是在欺负韭菜
做空只是个人看法吗
做空是做善事
做空为什么做善事
你想想看
你假如是个韭菜
你发现股票在涨的时候
你冲进去追
对
你一定会买在高点
假如这时候有人适时的放空
对
你就可以买便宜点
对不对
没错吧
不会这么想好不好
那假如跌下來
跌下來你寒冷你想要砍掉的時候
假如有人在這時候回補
你就不用砍的價格那麼差
但是我必須強調
除非是那種什麼國際突嬰
之前不是有那種國際突嬰
故意跟你一筆這樣
現貨壓灌砂下去
然後順便放空
這種很壞
除非這種當然很壞
可是其實一般人本來對多空就有判斷
做空其實是多一種手法
其實我們都說
跟你做同樣方向的人
才是你的敵人
跟你一起搶這檔股票的兜他
跟你例如說
兜他把股票炒上去
假設你買長榮
隔壁的大媽也買長榮
那我問你 你跟他是朋友還是敵人
事實上他是你的敵人
我們是競爭者
為什麼
因為他會比我先賣掉
對 有一天長榮大漲的時候
他先賣
兜他賣下來
他的價格賣得比你好
好不好
做同方向的才是敵人
做對象的才是好朋友
你要買的時候他在賣
你們兩個你買的價格就不會那麼高
他賣的價格不會那麼低
你們才是好朋友
所以融券跟融資彼此是好朋友
彼此是好朋友觀念要改變
而且還有一個重點
至少你看壞的時候
你會用融券你可以保護你自己
但是很多人的習性
他真的不擅長做空
因為反向思考有點困難
而且做空很容易被嘎到天上去
无边界也
无边界泳池
所以我们都说三月份做空的人
你好好的去看樱花好不好
所以现在来教的还是做多
吃空单豆腐的做多
大家要不要开心一点
对开心
因为最近三月份
三月份通常是讲殖利率的季节
那等到三月底
就很多股票要融卷强制回补
强制回补的时候
有些空难会受不了
来看第一个
我们先来了解
先解释一下
因为还是有新朋友
新朋友第一季没有看
就想看第三季的
要知道凶手是谁
第一季没看
凶手是谁
你知道是谁了吗
知道已经有人剧透爆雷了
剧透了
不爆不爆
来看第一个
這個融券呢
他就是手上沒有股票
那先向券商借股票來賣
很多人對這個借股票來賣
他又不懂了
那頭腦就打結了
反正就是跟人家借股票來賣
想說你的股票變成複數的意思
融資就是借錢買股票
融券就是先把股票借來賣掉換錢
沒錯
那第二個呢
再買進股票
未來呢你總是要還人家
那還價的時候呢
你就要再買一件股票來還給證券公司
那這個動作呢就叫做回補
那農券強制回補的時間呢
一年呢通常有兩次
一次呢就是股東會召開錢的兩個月還有出現期日前或者有時候會有現金增資這有時候很討厭不過還有人會召開臨時股東會整你
偶爾也會有這種情形
所以我們都講
龍券你不要跟人家講
不要糟告天下
被人家發現部位是件很恐怖的事情
對
那個妖孽事件就這樣
被人家發現部位了
對
就嘎你一波
好
第四個股東會前兩個月就必須要強制回補
最後回補日是停止過日前的六個營業日
每年股東會忘記大概就是五月底六月初
所以最近三月底四月初
就一堆龍券強制回補
龍券強制回補有的就會卡空
龍券你可以在證交所
有一個停券預告
證交所 各位你在證交所的首頁交易資訊
這裡有這個停券的預告表
像最近光群雷最後回補日
21號可神 今天
敦陽科日勝這幾個 陽明今天
這個預告表是預告多久呢
這個之前就會預告了
很久之前就會預告
預告告訴你 這是準備要強制回補
好
那你知道强制回補呢
我们就可以来计算一下
好
我们来计算什么东西呢
我们就来计算
这个
龙圈回补力道
是
那龙圈回补力道怎么算呢
这是我定义的
很简单啦
就是龙圈余额
对
再除以
这五日成交军量
等于这个五日的成交军量里面
有多少人在放空
对不对
这多少人得回补
多少人得回补
等於放空的人得回補
得回補
那我們假如找籌碼集中的
融券多的
他就融有剛剛的行情
最好是越線越抖越好
好 第三個
這個融券多
融資餘而少了
對 所謂的券資比
他券資比就會很高
那像這種
因為這個券資比高
到後面會出現一個問題
什麼問題
他容易被收標課費
沒有勸了
所以那種回補的力道會更強
好 那在強制回補日的時候
這個龍圈放空股票一定要提早回補
所以你就可以利用這種遊戲規則
那你就可以來做多這種軋空股票
那假如遇到怎麼樣
遇到強制回補日後
強制回補日後回歸正常
他就有機會下跌了
好 小哥這邊問一下
很多人會問勸資比高到底多少較高
好 這個很麻煩喔
因為每檔股票可能有點不一樣
有沒有標準呢
通常我們講勸資比高大概30%就很高了
30%以上這個勸資比高
我還看過5、60%的耶
5、60%大概就口難被咬住了
最近有一檔叫綠電
哇 你說他綠電喔
真是恨啊 怎麼沒有他
他每天都紅電
怎麼會是綠電
他叫電綠
電那些綠的人
對 照我聰明
電那些放空的
電那些放空的人
這個之前有人放空
哇 一放空立馬被所掌停
然後結果隔天一開門就問你
你要補嗎 不補再所掌停
這好可怕
太狠了
那這種股票都是先軋空
後面會容易再殺多
容易再殺多
所以勸支比以30為例
對不對
還有剛剛有提到
回補喔
就是在所謂的回補日前
大家會陸續回補
有沒有說有個規律
大概前幾天會特別強或什麼的
好 那我們講
前幾天會特別強
我們就看它的線型
線型越陡
它回補力道越強
那線型假如比較空頭
回補力道就沒那麼強
好
力道越強它就長得越兇
所以回補力道
你就用這個計算就可以了
融圈餘額除以
我們算5日的成交均量
比例越高 回補力道越強
比例越高 這邊又要問了
小哥快被我煩死
高是多高
50%以上
越高就是越強
50%以上就高了
因為常常會有人問趙華
今天是融眷最後回補路
會不會今天大噴可是好像也不一定不一定因為為為什麼這個有個很大的問題啊就是怎樣這個今日強制回補
各位啊
我們知道空難得強制回補嗎
對
你知道我知道
阿宅嘛知道
那個主力也知道
是
那主力想說
今天強制回補
今天最後一天
只剩今天有買盤了
還不趁今天到
趁什麼時候到
是
所以不見得回補日最強
前幾天可能就醞釀了
所以有時候你也不用等到最後一天
你有賺就可以跑
有賺就跑
你多單有賺就可以跑
好 我們先來做經典回顧
好
每次講農券強制微博
我就想到了這張
這張就會讓我想
怎麼沒空到它
這張真的太經典了
來看一下
它在這裡
在這邊剛好炒一個比特幣的行情
是
各位你記得比特幣大概四年會炒一次
四年會炒一次
因為它四年會說一次
折半嘛
四年炒一次
上次呢
哇第一次炒的時候
哇這比特幣
因為這個上回上漲
一路漲喔
各位你看喔
它從25塊
漲到了420
不要看這個不抖
這超級誇張噴的
這很誇張
25到420
這幾倍喔
這快20倍
那我們來看一下
它這420
你知道420出現在什麼時候嗎
什麼時候
出現在
是榮券強制回補日的隔天
隔天
它也不是那一天喔
你知道為什麼嗎
為什麼
因為榮券強制回補日
是跟你講說
你這天一定要給我補喔
所以空單的燃料燒到那一天結束了
所以大部分乖同學
老師跟你講
你今天一定要交作業喔
大部分人都今天會交
但是有些人是皮皮的
我就是不想交
你可以不交啦 沒關係
明天券商幫你補
所以他隔天還有不死心的人是券商幫你補
對
太痛了是吧
這一天420是券商補的
這跟斷頭真的一模一樣
真的一模一樣
然後最狠的是
最狠的是怎樣你知道嗎
很多人的空單是補在420
然後不甘心
我要再空回來
沒得空
最後回補那天
因為龍券強制回補不能空了吧
它又沒有股票期貨
沒股票期貨你也不能空
除非你去找認售權證來買
通常到這個地方
認售權證大概都算0.01、0.02了
也不值得買
等到終於可以空了
那一天
多少錢
剩下340塊
少了
可能了
80塊而已
少了80塊錢
還好啦 還可以
很多人看到80塊沒了就不爽了
沒送
我這80塊 這是什麼爛制度啊
沒有這種制度的話多好啊
那這個很多人就不想再去空
結果又回到100塊
哇賽 欸340到100也很大一段耶
所以你看先嘎空再殺多
但是那個過程中
如果公司派做了一些什麼東西
例如召開一些什麼臨時的什麼股東會
又要被回補
所以做空說實話限制真的比較多
做空沒人權啦
沒人權
還是少做啦
你有聽過做空的在召開
這個成立自救會嗎
沒有
沒聽過嘛
台灣只有那種做多
被殺下來的人
被砍下來的成立自救會
那做空的都沒有
沒人權耶
做空沒有啊
做空成立自救會
被笑
會被人家笑
你就是那個在看夕陽的賀
好
那我們再看一下這個
今年的
剛剛講是之前的
今年呢 今年各位看一下
這邊啊 華新
也一路漲上來
一路漲上來 龍券
就大幅的減少 為什麼 強制回復
所以這一段漲上來的過程中
龍券也幫了一點忙
因為也有孽架題材
對對對 孽架題材
後面他就殺下來
好 那接下來我們來看
放空滑心有點沒意思吧
人家股價那麼曲尖牛皮
那一檔比較沒意思
比較有意思的是這一檔
中貴
中貴各位看一下
中貴漲上來的過程中
龍卷也減少
這一段最明顯
你們可以看到
龍卷大減之後
這三天都沒卷
這就停止龍卷三天不能玩三天那你看龍券也是被迫補在高點比較可憐所以我們利用這種想法
我們設計了一張表
這個表連比率你剛剛講的
補率均量跟龍券餘額的比例也有嗎
也有
那張表就是龍券回補力道監控表
股東會偏
最近呢
这个我们也可以一档一档看
最近排名第一名的
叫做佳穎
好陌生
很陌生
他有发可转债的
他的劝补力道有到296%
你刚刚不是说50%以上就很高了吗
296%什么概念
不过他有15天
他可以慢慢消化
15天
农券油有478张
5日的成交均量
只剩下165张
它量很少耶
量很少卷通
量很少还去空它
是不是有点危险啊
好
那问题来了
奇怪干嘛去空它
诶 有没有看到
有发行可转载
有套利的行为吗
对
因为它这档
它的可转载市值
现在在150
所以它在这个位置
是有套利空间的
那有套利空间
各位你看到这张表
你又看到有这个
有发行可转载
对
然后可转载的市值
又在130以上的
他通常就沒有回補力道
因為他有套利空間的
所以他是為了可轉債去鎖這個空單嗎
對 那這種空單他不用補上去
因為有發可轉債
所以他只要把可轉債拿去換
可以換成股票
那股票就可以拿去還了
所以這種即使他的勸補力道比率那麼高
我們也先不要考慮他
你不要做它
你反而要去找後面的
像什麼山桑壽
它們有可轉載的
財端 浩鼎 光耀 新巨科
那找這幾個
找這幾個剩餘交易日比較少的
所以交易日越少
它因為一定要回補了
所以找剩餘交易日少的會比較好
我們來看一下
這邊有個4天
4天的互動
不過互動也有可轉載
互動可轉債最近也有在換
對
因為我有在做
我每天都在換互動可轉債
是
我每天換 你知道為什麼嗎
為什麼
我每天我就第一買可轉債都買得到
對
買到之後呢
就把互動可轉債換成股票賣掉
因為它在市場上賣的價格比較漂亮
是
我每天做的小套利
就是買可轉債換成現股賣掉
買可轉債換成現股賣掉
有人在做這個事情
我每天都在做這個事情
互动它的值率又高
所以通常你买可转债
你也怕跌
值率高我也不怕跌
有一个护城河
不怕跌
所以这几档各位
你可以研究一下
庄安表就蛮多的
标的蛮多的
不过今年
由于乌俄战争的关系
三月份很多股票跌下来
所以今年的擀空力道
你说小哥有没有像汉迅这种
还真的没有
没像汉迅这种这么腰的
然后又是被迫强制回补的
这种股票就比较少
那我们只好去找那种
没有这么腰
那也有可能有回补力道
但回补力道就没有汉迅这么强的股票
好
所以这个意思就是小哥会来帮我们做功课
因为我们听了这么多
因为他还要去算什么
五日均量跟融卷余
很多人就说哎呀我不会算了
好 沒關係 表格幫你列出來
列出來 哎呀又要看有沒有發可轉債
因為可轉債是索利用的嘛
好 所以小哥會在我們的榮耀班
好 找出一些很可能有融券回補
軋空行情的股票來分享給大家囉
好 這個融券回補潮
是一年有兩度的大勢
最近是因為要召開股東會前的
最後強制回補
不過因為最近的行情不太好
所以這一波的回補潮
也許不會非常強勁
但是還有第二波
還有第二波
就是除全席籤
所以現在趕快學起來
這一波沒有賺到沒關係
除全席籤
你還有一次機會
我們都來試試看好不好
看能不能學以致用
好 那今天的歌有收必報
就到這邊了
我們下次再會
拜拜